gonna run for
four days today
through thursday
uh the schedule is online so uh
i'm sure i mean everyone who is here
obviously found the links
but uh tell people to register and then
they'll get links to attend
automatically we registered i think all
authors and all pc members as panel as a
panelist
so uh you should be able to access one
word of warning
if you access through gather town uh i
think you you become
an attendee so it's it's uh it's it's
not just it's potentially not the same
link as the one you got in your email
but
that's at least that's been my
experience
so uh
a couple of words about
this year's itcs
obviously it's
virtual some uh statistics so it's been
a record year in terms of submissions
about uh 50
more than last year
uh
we got about 250 submissions
uh there were even more
pre-registrations but this was about the
number of submissions we accepted 120
papers
the year uh
uh has been very strong in terms of
papers so
essentially all the papers that we
accepted
someone really wanted to see in the
program
we added an extra day compared to
previous atcs's which was
relatively simple to do because we are
online
uh while maintaining a single track so
it's gonna be the program is about 26
hours
over four days including graduating bids
uh
there are no concurrent sessions we had
59 pc members
uh
across
a very broad set of areas
uh
about 320 external reviewers
uh
a large number of reviews this was just
the number of words counts it's i was
curious i i ran it from uh
when i backed up all the reviews offline
to see this so it's it's actually
it was pretty amazing to see both the
qualities of the papers and the quality
of the reviewing process which is kind
of
people worked really hard
and
the discussion was really high quality
and
we got an exciting program as a result
uh and they hope that in both cases when
we accepted papers and when we didn't
the reviews were actually helpful for
kind of for the field and for
whatever happens next to the papers
so this was uh
very challenging to organize both
because
i mean we planned it as a hybrid from to
begin with
but uh still it's eventually we went all
virtual
uh
and
but there is still there were still a
lot of tasks with a relatively lean
operation
uh so simon's institute
some representatives are here
really did a lot of the administrative
and av and uh including this zoom and
gather which you got information for and
we should use for breaks
uh we got some sponsorship money from
google that allows us
so we couldn't keep registration at zero
but we managed to
keep it relatively low compared to
other events so and uh we eventually
decided to only charge it on papers and
let people so all the content is free so
people are free to attend the conference
people are free to read the papers there
are no and there is no
painful paywall
so
to disseminate the content all the
videos are on youtube
the papers on an open access and you can
get a link to register to attend talks
by
basically registering on the simon's
website
uh
we got so the money is actually handled
in mit so that's uh it's actually just
collecting it and giving it to the
publishers and
that's a task that uh
it's it it turns out you have to have
someone do it
uh
the steering committee it's been
handling a lot of questions and uh
kind of uh
especially uh ronit but uh
the entire steering committee sharing
their experience and kind of directing
the conference and most importantly it's
the authors uh i think
the quality of the papers keeps
increasing and
the pc members and reviewers who really
did an amazing work and it was also a
relatively tight time frame that we did
it in and basically everything had to be
done over
from mid-september to mid-october
and
[Music]
they
really did a
very good job
uh
so we have two best student paper awards
uh who will be presented i one i think
is today
uh
but
it's in the schedule
one on deterministic dynamic matching
and other in
about a gaussian fixed point random walk
so congratulations
uh so an announcement about safety oc i
don't know if one of the representatives
wants to speak or should i continue i
mean
uh
yeah i can speak or you can also
continue so sumer i don't know i mean
you probably have more experience okay
okay okay i can see so uh i am one of
the safe doc advocates for itcs this
year
uh safetyoc is a group of volunteers
formed to help prevent and combat
harassment in the toc community
uh i wanted to take these few minutes to
reiterate ipc's commitment towards a
safe and inclusive conference experience
uh if you experience or witness
discrimination harassment or any other
unethical behavior at the conference
in addition to reaching out the pc chair
or steering committee chair
please note that you also have the
option of reaching out to
me or tom good
to seek advice and remedy
our emails are also provided in the code
of conduct section section on the
website
uh and uh finally
if you want it would if you would like
to volunteer for to be a safety of the
advocate or know more about the
role please visit uh the website
safetyofc.org for more information
okay uh
thank you so meg and of course you can
also if
problems occur you can also reach out to
me and to the steering committee to
ronit and
as an additional option so uh we'll do
what we can
uh okay
yeah that's the website
so some practical information so the
schedule is online we have because uh so
we we are running a single track but uh
there are
no
some sections are back to back so to
avoid kind of being kicked out of rooms
we run into
there are two rooms a and b so just uh
if you want to attend the section check
which room you are
you need to be in
we have a gather a link that you should
you should get let us know if you didn't
from when you registered
uh
that because there are pre-recorded
talks the format of the exact format of
the session is up to chairs so you
should
hear from your session chairs were also
listed
please email me i guess you you already
unless you spam filtered the
itcs chair at gmail you have my email
and and you can
reach out to me if there are any
questions
the proceedings are online almost all
the videos on the youtube channel
and linked from the schedule
uh
if there are any problems with any of
those also reach out to us
and
thank you and enjoy tcs and
i really hope that next year there will
be no more uh virtual participation or
at least it will only be used for good
like to allow more people to attend but
not to restrict
our ability to interact in person but
um
hopefully next year it will be in person
uh
so uh the first
session will start in three minutes
uh so who is the first uh
chair uh i'm the first cmr so i can take
it from here don't worry thank you okay
thank you and uh
we'll be on gather when not during talks
so we should hang out there
thank you thank you
so we are going to start in the three
minutes uh if you are one of these
speakers for session one and you're
still not a panelist please let us know
so you can be
upgraded thank you
yeah i'm gonna check if you're a
panelist just
no it doesn't look like you are so mark
do you know who has access and can
promote people
i don't know if i ca i cannot promote or
i don't know how to promote but who
should i promote
okay so we have the following speakers
oh i can promote people yeah okay so the
first one is michael ezra and i think
yeah
it's already panelist
yep i'm here
okay uh we also have
uh bruno cavallar
uh and he's also a panelist
uh and then we have uh grieznov is the
second author from the third paper yes
it's there
uh and then bring more
it seems brimmer is not yet penalized
okay okay grace and then chris jones
yeah also finalist so i think we are
yeah
i think we're by default i gave the list
of all the speakers of all the authors
but of course there could be problems
uh but
are you able to promote because i can
say under more promote to panelists
anyone who wants to be promoted by the
way just
put it in the chat because we there is
nothing will go wrong even if you
promote everyone
yeah i don't think i can promote but
yeah please write it in the chat
so i think we can probably start um
so welcome to the first session so this
is about circuit complexity theory
uh so we have five talks and since we
have just 60 minutes the plan is to have
uh
at most 10 minutes for each talk and
then two minutes for questions
so the first speaker is going to be
michael ezra
uh michael would you like to try to
share a string to see if it's working
fine
yeah
and
all
right right uh great so yeah so talk of
us about uh small circuits imply
efficient automatic protocols thank you
michael over to you
all right so hi everyone
hey i'm michael
and today i will tell you about a new
connection between circuits say lower
bounds and protocols that are called
automatic protocols
so our pattern is called small circuits
you play efficient automating protocols
and our story starts with an open
question in seconds complexity
that asks for the dnf of parties which
is a circuit that has struggles at the
bottom and then a dna for the top
can approximate the inner product
functions
and our results show that a positive
answer for this open question yields to
very efficient automatic protocols which
actually seems to be too good to be true
and therefore they actually can serve as
an evidence for the answer for this open
question is apparently negative
so what is our domain protocol so
automate particle is a protocol between
two parties we have out of the verifier
which is limited resources machine that
tries to solve some decision problems
auto must be efficient but is the law to
interact with merlin
which has infinite computational power
and the catch is that merely is untested
it might be malicious so auto must
analyze the information that is provided
by merlin in order to verify that merlin
doesn't type the following so we have
the completeness property that says that
if x in the language then the verifier
accepts without probability and the
sourness that says that if x is not in
the language then no matter what the
proverb does the verifier rejects with
our probability
and in our work we actually
don't focus on traditional outdoor mind
protocols we actually focus on variants
of our domain particles that called out
domain data streaming and automation
cache complexity protocols so i result
in a little bit more details say that if
we assume the existence of a polynomial
size then of parities that compute the
inner power function correctly on more
than five over six fraction of the
inputs then we get very efficient
automating streaming and automating
complexity protocols for wide collection
of problems
so i still need to define what are these
data streaming and automation cache
complexity models but before that i want
to make a quick overview about what is
known and what is unknown about the
relation between bone and circuits and
the inner product functions
so let's start with the s 0 circuits
which are constant f circuits that use
only n o and not gates and actually
ready from the 8 is we know that with t
circuits we cannot compute or
approximate the parity function
which is a special case of the inner
product functions so in particular we
cannot compute or approximate the inner
product function
however that in
particular circuits it's actually very
easy to compute the inner product
function
so without party guess it is hard to
configure in a quarter function but with
power decades it's very easy so the next
question is what happens if you allow
the use of power to get in the circuits
but it can only be used on the very
first layer of the circuits
such circuits
um
are called ac zero parties and about seo
of parties we actually don't know to say
whether we can or cannot compute any
product function
we do know some weak low bounds in the
general case or some strong global
bounds in
in some respected cases but you don't
know what happened but but you don't
know a stronger bond in the general case
and lastly we have the case of the end
of authorities so in the end of parties
we actually know that we cannot compute
the inner product function correctly but
we don't but we know this result only
for exact computation we don't know what
happens in approximation we don't know
whether the enough part is can a
approximate a dino product function
so back to our result what we are going
to do now is to define what are our
domain stream and ultimate concave
capacity models and then we will see the
formal version of our results so let's
start with the streaming model an
automatic strength protocol is actually
going to be a combination between
automatic protocol and the traditional
streaming model
so into the in the traditional stream
model we have only one party which is
unbounded in time and it is required to
compute some target function f
we are unlimited in time but we have two
restrictions
first we must use only a small amount of
space and in particular sub-linear space
and second we don't have a full access
to the input
instead we get the input a sequence of
bits that is called a stream
and after reading some beating sequence
we cannot longer we read it again
so this is the traditional explaining
protocol and in the out to main data
stream protocol
we actually first run a public
interaction between merlin and auto and
after that we wanted a deterministic a
strange protocol that depends on the
input and on the transcript of the
initial uh public coin interaction
and again we have the copays property
and the sourness property
so the next step is to define what is
automation cache complexity a model so
again we'll start with the traditional
chromecast complexity model so in the
traditional comcast complexity
complexity model we have two parties we
have alice and bob
and alice and above try to to compute
some joint function f that depends on an
input x that is given to alice and an
input white and it is given to bob
and the goal for instant book is to
conduct some interaction in which in the
end both of them
know the value of the function f and
they're going to do it by exchanging the
least amount of bits between alice and
bob
so in the automatic version of the
communication complexity model will also
add some untrusted over so the part is
first run a public coin interaction with
the prover which obviously sees both x
and y
and then the parties run the traditional
communication complexity protocol
and if both alice and bob accepts then
the protocol a
is accepting the input
so now we can speak about the formal
version of our results
so by having an assumption about dnf of
parties that
the independent function we actually get
four kinds of protocols
so assume that we have the nfl parties
that approximately inform a function to
a factor that is greater than five over
six
we get the following efficient kinds of
protocols
first we get our domain stream protocol
for every degree b polynomial where the
number of rounds in the interaction is d
and the proof length and space
complexity are quasi linear indie and
logarithmic with the number of input
bits of the polynomials
and just to give you some intuition
about the efficiency of the protocol
so if i take d to be a constant
then we actually get a a constant number
of ones and a logarithmic complexities
which is actually an exponential
improvement
for a solution that is based on the
famous subject protocol
so simply by having some assumption
about the dna for parties
we get an exponential improvement to the
centric protocol
and the second result is the standard
protocol for a problem is called the
parity triangles problem in that problem
a
the goal is to count the partial number
of triangles in a gas so in the
particles problem we get a strain
protocol with only one round of
interaction and a poly logarithmic
capacity
the first result is in the co is in the
communication complexity model so in the
concussion complexity model we also get
a protocol for ddg polynomials but this
time with only one round of interaction
so by simply having an assumption about
the enough particles we get
complexity protocol with with one round
of interaction and only logarithmic
communication capacities
and lastly by taking the previous result
and using osboro and smallansky technics
we also get a automation communication
complexity protocol for ac 0 circuits
with only one round of interaction and
poly logarithmic communication
complexity
so by simply having some assumptions
about different benefit parties we
actually get these four kinds of
protocols which are a far more efficient
than than the protocols that we know for
these problems
so in the last minutes that i have left
i want to say a single or two words
about some open problems
uh and further directions that are
related to our work
so first in our work uh we start with
some assumption about dna for parties
that approximately report function to a
factor that is greater than five over
six
it will be interesting to try to push
the five over six factor to something
that is a
more close to a one over two
it also be interesting to be able to
construct protocols for s zero also in
the spring model so currently we know
how to do it only in the complexity
model
and the third direction which i think is
it is the most motivating direction
is to find efficient protocols also for
problems in nc1 class where lower bounds
are actually known and the reason i
think this
direction
is actually the most interesting is
because most of the non-interactive
protocols for problems in seran
actually mainly
use the subject protocol
and we actually get an improvement and
and sometimes even an exponential
improvement to the subject protocol
but yet we still didn't success to a get
protocols of problems in nc1 even that
it feels like
we should have
and having success or progress in that
direction actually give us the desired
lower bound benefits because there are a
non lower bounds a importance in c1
and lastly
of course the golden goal is to
show some a circular bond show that the
nf parties cannot approximately in a
portal function
so a thanks for listening a doctor's
office small circuits apply efficient
automatic protocols and i guess that we
now reach to the part of the questions
thank you very much for the talk please
let us know if you have questions let me
just ask a quick one is that a simple
explanation for this five over six
threshold
sorry
is there an explanation for this five
over six
that is not too too technical or
yeah so
actually a
so i
skip to the slide
okay so actually in the a
the construction of the port
so i need to define to extend the entire
flow of the construction of the
protocols to answer that question but i
will just say that there is a moment in
the construction five protocols where we
try to build a
an am protocol that can verify in the
product lines
and we have a some protocol a
preliminary protocol that works only on
a
most input so it talks only with
hyper-ability over the inputs
and in order to get from that protocol a
protocol that works on all the inputs
and we actually use something that is
called small the self caution of the
inner product function which led us to
instead of verify
verifying a a single a
in a product climb we try to verify a
some random product lines
and you know and and to be able to uh
to verify
all these inner product lines we need to
be able to verify a single random unit
product line a with the probability that
it's greater than five over six and that
probability comes from the approximation
of the inner product function of the
idea of particles for the inner function
so there's a question for in the chat
yeah much
i don't understand what do you mean by
the storm notation approximation
so i think shahi is asking uh
we already have worst case lower bounds
and i think he's asking about what's
knowing the average case like if there
is an extension
why the a stone low bounce doesn't work
also in the a in approximation
i i i didn't think that understand
the question right so much is there a
way to promote
let me try
uh
a
anyway yes there are low bounce so
i don't i i don't think that i
understand the question but i will say
that
there are uh
there is a lower bounce through
uh
there's more low ones in the worst case
but it definitely
should be promoted now yeah okay thank
you
so yeah instead of this low band that
dnf parity is kind of exactly computes
in a product
and i'm wondering if the is the same the
proof there also gives that it cannot
like you know really strongly
approximate
in the product as well or this is just
for worst case
and so i think it is just for the worst
case
if i understand your question right
um
anyway a the test that works for the
worst case a
doesn't pull out this
a constant approximation
what for example would it give you that
you cannot take one minus one over n
approximate it or one is exponential or
i don't know something
so i
you mean
one minus one
over poly yeah
and so i have to say that hey i don't
really remember
uh
i think from what i recorded it can root
out one minus one over exponential
um
but uh haven't looked at it in a while
okay thanks
so i think we need to move on to the
next talk so mark i was wondering if
there's a way to just promote everyone
to finalists so they can ask questions
and if we have an issue we can like do
something about it but i think this will
be much easier
so uh bruno
maybe we can start if you're talking we
would like to try to share a screen
please
yeah we can't hear you yet can you see
my screen and can you hear me also
yes we can hear you so yeah so for the
second talk of the session we have bruno
cavallar bruno is going to tell us about
comparative circuits thank you bruno
over to you thank you
yeah so this is my joint work with jin
jin lou
it's entitled algorithms and lower
bounds for comparative circuits from
shrinkage
so what are comparator circuits um
comparator circuits can simply be
defined as boolean circuits with which
um only contain comparator gates
um
and you can consider the the negations
to be at the bottom and comparator gates
um are as follows each gate has a fan
out too
so it's a bounded fan out model that's
what it's trying to capture
um and uh
each comparator gate has two wires and
one of the wire um contains the result
of the ore of the incoming bits and the
other wire has the end of the incoming
bits
okay so that's a
comparative circuit
one equivalent representation
which um is people usually have in mind
when talking about comparator circuits
is uh is as in this picture you have a
set of horizontal lines which we call
wires
and they are labeled with literals
um
and each gate is in this representation
is an ordered pair of wires which is
represented in the figure as an arrow
between two wires so the tip of the
arrow is the or gate and the bottom of
the error is the end gate
in this particular figure you have a
comparator circuit with two inputs
uh four wires
and four gates and the third wire
computes the parity of the two incoming
bits
so what what is known about comparison
circuits i just do not here on cc
uh to the class of problems solved by
polyscience comparison circuits
as i see brackets says those they are
solved by size as comparator circuits
and here i'm thinking of size as the
number of
comparator gates
so
simulations um
it's easy to see that you can
simulate a formula of size s by a
comparator circuit of size s you can
just copy the formula
but we already have a contrast here
parity you can compute with linear size
comparator circuits just by um
repeating the construction of a previous
slide but it's also well known that
parity requires quadratic science
formulas
it's also known that non-deterministic
branching programs can be simulated by
comparator circuits with only a
polynomial overhead
as a consequence this gives us that nc1
which is contained in nl
they're both contained in this class cc
it's also conjecture to being comparable
to the class nac of polylog time
parallel computation
uh there are some evidence people give
so
first stable marriage is a problem that
can be solved by comparator circuits but
it's not um
expected to be in nc because all the
algorithms
uh that we have been able to think about
for this problem so far
um
are inherently sequential
and there's also more recently oracle
separations given by cook films and lee
2014
and also separation uh
in the monotone world
uh the the specific case of majority is
one in which we still don't know
the precise complexity in in the
comparative circuit model
uh so we know that there's a comparator
circuit with a linear number of wires
and then log in gates computing majority
but it's unknown whether we can do it
with just a linear number of gates or if
there is a superlinear bound for
majority on comparative circuits
so the first lower bound for comparator
circuits in the monotone world was
proved in 2016 by robert pitassi rosman
cook it was an exponential rebound
and the first lower mount for a
non-monotone world for non-monotone
comparator circuits was proved by a
governor bear 2019 now over 30 years uh
since
the model was first studied
it was uh
uh and over login to the one point five
worst cases were bound for some
functions in p
and um
another technique basically is an
adaptation of net products but with a
crucial new structural result but
compared to circuits which they proved
so what are our results um we proved the
first average case worth bound for
comparative circuits and our
learned bound matches governor bears
first case bound
and we show the first circuit analysis
algorithm it's algorithms for
comparative circuits so it's a class of
algorithms they're a crucial step when
we try to understand a circuit class
such algorithms are known for ac0 acc
demorgan formulas benching programs and
other on circuit models
in particular we show accounting set
algorithms to run our generators and
learning algorithms um for this circuit
class
so
first our average keys are about um
average case complexity is well
motivated for all of us i think
it's a it's a definition of cryptography
and perhaps gives us a handle on
more realistic inputs
so um more concretely what we show is
that for every k there's a
polynomial time computable function f k
on n bits
such that uh any circuit um any
comparator circuit with at most entropy
1.5
over
o to the k
times square root of log n gates um
can't be can't can't agree with this
function
on more than one half plus a factor that
decreases explanation with k
uh number of inputs
okay and uh if you let in particular if
you choose k to be big of logan
you retrieve uh governor bears bound
so
we do and
time restrictions of just talk about um
the coding side algorithm
so we know that satellite np complete
and and also conjecture not to have
uh sub explanation time algorithms
um but we can also of course ask about a
question of whether there exists
other exists non-trivia algorithms for
satisfiability and that's a
well-motivated question and williams
in 2013 also showed that
this question is also important from the
point of view of complexity
in particular he showed that non-trivial
satisfiability algorithms often can be
used
to prove circular amounts
so with that in mind we
we show a non-trivial algorithm um a new
three percetability algorithm
for comparator circuits
uh so our algorithm it counts the number
of satisfying segment assignments of a
given comparator circuits
that has roughly into the 1.5 gates
um
and for a particular choice of
parameters
uh when
the size is roughly and over login to
the 1.5
we get a non-trivial runtime okay
so our techniques
um we we
we apply the the well-established
technique of shrink rate under render
restrictions with high probability
uh so the idea is that um when we
randomly fix a fraction p of the values
of some variables the size of the
circuit shrinks by a factor between the
gamma for some gamma greater zero with
high probability
it's just a
yet a
well-known technique
and uh it's known that um
shrinkage can be used to show average
gizzler bounds and several random
generators
and what we do is we show that shrinkage
can also be used to analyze comparator
circuits
um it's not obvious at first how that
can be done when you
um randomly physic fix a
fraction of the values of the variables
let's say if you if you just fix the the
value of a wire in the worst case you
may eliminate only one gate
so we show how how
how shrinkage can also be used to
analyze comparator circuits and we give
more detail analysis which gives us um
on the matching lower bounds
so an open problem uh of course
can we improve the analysis from engine
1.5 to entity 1.51
it will be implied for instance by a
better shrinkage result
with gamma greater than one-half um
is this the best possible is it the best
that our current techniques can achieve
or is there a better
analysis for comparator circuits
in particular
there's also the question about hardness
magnification
can we show that engine 1.5 load balance
for comparator circuits for specific
functions have major consequences in
complexity theory
it's not hard to show that and and to
the 2.01 is enough but it's far from the
best lower bounds so how far are we from
them
from the magnification threshold
and finally um approx the approximation
method uh is a very general technique
that can be used to capture
uh non-deterministic branching programs
for instance
uh and it was used also to buy raspberry
to prove super linear lower balance for
majority and since comparator circuits
can also simulate deterministic range of
programs
it's a natural question to ask if
this technique can also capture
comparator circuits and perhaps be used
to prove their bounds for majority
yep
thank you
thanks a lot bruno
questions for bro
okay if there are no questions thanks
again bruno for giving this talk thank
you
so the next pk is going to be kriyasnov
uh yeah hello everybody
uh
yeah please try to share this thing
right now i can't see anything
and
yes okay great so yeah
so next talk is about uh we see
dimension with applications so that
three circuits
um
and we are very happy to have kriyasnov
so if you could please tell tell us or
tell me how to pronounce your first name
there's a bigger uh it it is
okay
thank you
over to you
yeah okay uh hello everybody uh i'm
cesar grisnoff and i will talking about
our joint work with peter franco and
navita and bonfart and the height of the
paper is a variant of the vc dimension
with applications to the free circuits
so first let's recall the valence
program for improving
circuit level balance
and for this let's define sigma 3k as an
or and or circuit
where the bottom fan in is bounded by k
so when is the production give us the
following if we have a linear size log
depth circuit then we can rewrite it as
this side circuit uh the free circuit
where k is bounded like this
so if we have a strong exponential uh we
have exponential lower bounds for
definite circuits then we have super
linear lower bounds for
logarithmic depth circuits
and also galvanoff at all uh recently
proved that
if we have a strong exponential
overbound for that free circuit where
the bottom finding is 16
then we'll have a 3.9 overbound for
general circuits and as far as you know
it's
better than what we have right now
so
what we actually have no know about
solar bounds for depressed circuits
first if it if you don't restrict it uh
bottom finding then the general bound is
two to the square root of n
for the bottom five and k
uh we know that it is at least uh there
are functions that have complexes at
least two to the c n over k
and for bottom finding two we actually
have a strong exponential our bound that
is
the best possible
so let's uh dive a bit in the details
about the bottom falling too
so for this we need the notion of
projection and projection is simply a
fine space that is generated by
equations
that involve at most two variables so
they look like this
and
sorry particularly at all proved that if
you have
to cnf with at most n variables and it
has sufficiently large number of
satisfying assignments
then it contains a large projection
thus if you apply this result to a fine
distorters then we have the needed lower
bounds and strong exponential overbound
for these functions
a very initial question is whether we
can actually try to generalize this
notion its projections to free cnfs
and unfortunately the answer is no
and there are some free synapses that
have exponentially maintained
assignments but only accept
projections of constant size
but it doesn't rule out the case when we
consider not projections but maybe a
more general find some spaces
but for now let's first talk about uh
this lower bound
uh given by pattorious accent zane and
for this let's recall what vc dimension
is
so consider f to be capital of to be
a family of subsets
and we say that the set i is shattered
by f
if the trace of ion f that is
this intersection
contains all the subsets of i or
equivalently if you like to think about
subsets as a boolean strings
then the projection of f to the column
is i have to be the whole boolean cube
and this dimension defined by wapnic and
cervantes
is the size of the largest
eye that is shattered by f
so
if we know the vc dimension of a set can
we say anything about the set itself and
it turns out the answer is yes and uh
this is well-known fact proven by
zauer and sharla and let's say that if
you have a set with boundless vc
dimension that the size of the set is
bounded itself in terms of vc dimension
uh this bound is tight since having ball
of right sd gives the diet bound
and usually people use a counter
positive argument when working with a
slimmer so usually if we have
a set of exponential size then it has a
vc dimension of linear size
however
we cannot guarantee using this
a reasoning
we see dimension of size bigger than mm2
and hamming ball of radius and over 2
will show this since it has almost uh
to the to the n minus
minus some constant size but
unfortunately it has this dimension from
n over 2.
so
to tackle this problem and also some
other problems we introduce a very
natural variant of vc dimension and it
is called ur damage
so again let f be a family of subsets
and
we define your dimension as the size of
the largest i such as every subset of i
upset at most r is shattered by f
and as you remember previously we only
require for the c dimension only require
i to be shattered and now we require
only small subsets of i
so
obviously if r is not large is not large
then this thing is bigger than vc
dimension
and the question is whether we had some
analog of
our shellac lemma for this notion
the answer is yes and
for this first we need to formulate a
few things
so by alpha of h i will define the
maximum number from the maximum size of
independent set in a hyper graph
and alpha yeah and
it is an independent number of hyper
graphs
and then we also consider
numbers if nkr
that has a
maximum number of independent sets in a
hypergraph
of a regular hypograph with
n vertices and with bounded size of the
maximum dependence set
if you compare this notion with the reg
with the notion of two run numbers then
the run numbers is the smallest number
of edges achieving the same conditions
so let's recall what is the touring
theorem so transference says that
the unique graph is the minimum number
of edges that satisfy the
conditions above on the previous slide
is the disjoint union of clicks of the
same size
and zika's theorem is a generalization
of storage theorem that say that if you
want to maximize the number of
independent set
then this graph is also unique
thus we can apply zika's theorem and
prove this bound for i of nk2
so we have a bound for regular for usual
graphs not for
hypergraphs and this will allow us to
beat the thyroid lemma um since this
notion of ion kr closely related to ur
we can prove the following lemma and
that if you have a family of sets with
bounded u2 dimension then the size of f
is bounded by this formula
and
now we can actually guarantee
uh
u2 dimension to be arbitrary close to n
and b and the this d bound is better
than what we get
what we get from
this dimension from the usual so our
shallow lemma
so this was about graphs but do we
actually know anything about hyper grass
the answer is a bit more green in this
case
but we have something so if alpha the
independence number of graph is large
enough then it can prove that it is a
disjoint union of edges so it's a
degenerate case of clicks of size one
and for a general case we have a
conjecture that it seems that the joint
clicks of the same size have to be the
unique extrema case
and
if you're aware about the torrent
problem for this for hypergraph then it
is notoriously open and hard since we
don't since we don't even have a
conjecture about possible extrema
instances
but it doesn't seem to be the case for
our problem of maximizing number of
independent sets
and
at least for our small computer search
it was
like this
so let's just get back to the
circuits and
prove some tighter bound for bottom fan
2 using this notion of
using this notion of you are dimension
so the argument by paturi atoll
proves that the projection dimension for
two cnfs is exactly vc dimension of this
set of its satisfying assignments
so
we proved that for two cnns vc dimension
of the set and the u two dimension are
the same
thus we can actually apply not the
source element but our improved version
of this lemma for u2 dimension
and this will allow us to get
lower balance for a fine dispersers and
not for this i find dispersers of
sublinear dimension but even disperser
for linear dimension will be enough
and
in particular it will allow us to prove
the following result so if you have some
two cnns that is consistent with inner
product
then we can prove that it accepts at
most this number of system assignments
and this
is important and i will get back in a
few slides
uh we also have some humble progress
some partial results about free cnfs
and
using
this ur dimension twice
we can actually first use
some properties of e3 dimension to prove
that a free cnf with a lot of hispanic
assignments contains
as
a two c nif as a formula with a lot of
fine assignments
and then we can apply the previous lemma
to prove that it has to contain a large
projection and thus the original uh cnfl
contains also large projection and we
can apply
uh
similar reasoning as uh as the previous
say
so could you please
maybe like 30 seconds oh yeah
sorry
yeah that's basically the last slide so
yeah
uh yeah
i want to say that something similar can
be get from switching lemma but the
bound will be worser than worse than we
got
and under the conjunction will be even
more
and sorry um yeah so the summaries
we have these open problems and uh thank
you very much for listening
yeah
thank you
questions please
can you just put the the previous slide
with the
ip
uh which one
about the product
is that
so is this
so this actually goes back to the
question i was asking the previous talk
is this uh
this is the best
in approximate result for uh
no no this is about two things okay so
yeah so is it about
is this
uh sorry uh what's the question again
this is this is a better result that was
known for uh
for two cmfs
um
i mean this particular result is not
really that interesting
yes but but it's actually a bit
interesting in the sense if we want
uh to try to improve the current uh
current depth current level balance for
the free circuits for in the product
since for inner products we actually
don't have a a correct bound we have
some upper bounds somewhere bound and
the conjecture is that the current upper
bound is the best possible but
current techniques fail to prove it
and we have some we tried to apply some
kind of stability approach
so not only we prove that
this number of span assignments three to
the number two is the maximum uh we
prove that this construction is actually
unique
so there might be some kind of stability
approach to proving this balance but
we haven't finished it completely so
yeah it's one of the open problems to
continue working on this
thanks
thanks emmanuel
so if anyone has more questions please
ask them in the chat so we can start
with the next stock
so
brimor are you ready
okay the next talk is gonna yeah we can
see you so the next talk is gonna be
given by brimur chapman and it's going
to be about new upper bounds for ac zero
thank you
okay um hello everybody i'm i'm bryn
moore uh and uh today i'll be presenting
joint work with my advisor ryan
on smaller acc0 circuits for symmetric
functions
okay so first a brief introduction
this work studies the power of
mod gates
which count modulo's some natural number
m
and in particular in this work we
studied two complexity classes uh cc0
and acc0
and i i feel like i should apologize at
this point for a uh notation collision
um
in bruno's talk uh cc was uh comparator
circuits but uh here we use cc to mean
counting circuits um
so yeah sorry about that
uh
okay so what are these complexity
classes
uh many of you are probably already
familiar with
the complexity class ac0
uh so these are functions computable
with uh constant depth
uh circuit families
with
uh unbounded fan in
uh and consisting of and and or gates
and will allow any of these gates to be
negated freely so negations will not
count towards a circuit size or circuit
path
and if we change this definition
slightly and also allow mod gates
uh we'll get the complexity class acc0
um
and it's worth noting here that the
modulus m for the mod gates can vary
with the circuit family
or the function being computed but it
should not depend on the input size
and for contrast uh in the complexity
class ac 0 mod m
the modulus m will be fixed
even across circuit families
uh and finally uh if we only allow the
mod gates and we get rid of the uh and
and or gates
we'll get the complexity class cc0
and once again the modulus m
should not depend on the input size but
it can vary with the circuit family
okay
so uh one question we could ask is
how did these mod gates help
uh can they for instance
efficiently compute symmetric functions
like majority
uh it's well known that in ac 0
this will require exponential size
and uh ac 0 mod m
will also require super polynomial size
as long as m is a prime power
but on the other hand uh we don't know
much about non-prime power moduli
so for instance uh it's been conjectured
for years that the and function does not
have polynomial size
cc0 circuits
but it's still an open question whether
like not just and but
even every polynomial uh sorry every
exponential time decidable problem
can be computed with a polynomial size
circuit family
even if you only allow mods six gates
and depth three
so
it's kind of an embarrassing open
problem right
uh
but proving these lower bounds is rather
difficult and in this work we fed some
light on this difficulty
by proving that uh in fact cc0 may
actually be
somewhat more powerful than we
previously thought
okay so uh here's a brief overview of uh
of our results
uh our first result is that uh every
symmetric function
can be computed by depth three cc0
circuits
of sub-exponential size
and moreover these circuits have a nice
form
so the the top and bottom layers are
going to be
mod p1 gates
and the middle layer will be mod e2 by
p3 by
etc up to pr
and all of these pi's will be distinct
primes
we also show a trade-off between
circuit size
circuit depth
and the number r of prime factors of the
modulus n
so we can fairly easily get an additive
dependence on r and d in the
double exponent from the previous slide
and with a little more work we can uh
get a multiplicative dependence
uh turning this uh
n to the one over about r plus d
into something more like uh n to the one
over r times t
um and it turns out we can actually both
improve and simplify this ladder result
significantly by using acc0 instead of
cc0
uh so if we then allow these uh and and
or gates as well as mod gates
uh we'll get even smaller circuits
we can get this trade-off similar to uh
to the last theorem but we get a much
simpler construction and we also get
better constants in the double exponent
okay
so our results combine results from the
literature in new ways
so
i'll just give an intuitive overview of
the proofs
uh because that's all we really have
time for
uh so our constructions are based on the
following ac zero construction
uh
we're gonna focus without loss of
generality on the exact majority
function image
uh which outputs one if the if and only
if the sum of its inputs is exactly some
threshold d
and we'll see in a moment why this does
not lose generality
uh we're going to set some parameter
between
zero and one we'll call this delta
we're going to partition our inputs into
n to the delta groups
of n to the one minus delta inputs each
and then our circuit construction will
look approximately like this
we're going to take a big or over all
possible vectors
old t
whose l1 norm is our desired threshold t
and so that this is why we don't lose
generality by considering only image
because every symmetric function is just
going to be an or
of up to n imagines
and
so that means that we can
just sort of collapse this this big ore
into our top board here
and we'll blow up our circuit size by
about a factor of n
um
and now each input to this four
will be an and over all indices from one
to and to the delta
and
each
input to these and gates
is a cnf that determines whether the
inputs in group k
sum to t sub j
uh and notice that uh to balance the
fannins
we're going to want to set delta to be
one half
and then the the top or gate will have
fannin approximately two to the root n
the and gates of the c and f's
uh can be collapsed into the second
layer of and gates
which then has
uh also has fannin about two to the root
n
and the bottom layer of or gates will
have fanon about rudolph
and so then overall we're going to get a
circuit of size about two to the root n
okay
so now if we allow mod gates as well
we can improve this construction in the
following way
[Music]
so first we'll replace the top board
with the mod gate
instead of cnf circuits we'll use
much smaller mod circuits
and this will allow us to decrease delta
rebalance our fannins and we'll get a
smaller circuit overall
but then this will give us a layer of
bands of mods which we'll then need to
convert into
uh mod of mods
and finally we're going to have to
collapse uh
adjacent layers of mod gates
uh to get a single layer of mod base
and so this produces the
depth three circuits uh
for the for the first theorem that i
showed
and to get these uh the first size depth
trade-off
uh we observed that these cnfs are
themselves computing symmetric functions
and so we can iterate our depth
reconstruction
and then for the stronger size depth
trade-off
we'll instead use a slightly different
construction based on arithmetic
circuits which we can then simulate in
acc0
so now a natural extension of this work
would be to study what other
non-symmetric functions
can be computed similarly using log
gates
could we also construct uh smaller
circuits to
simulate nc1 or boolean formulas or
space bounded computation
uh and also
are
our trade-offs optimal
and under a fairly natural strengthening
of the
fairly widely believed hypothesis that
tc0 is not in acc0
the answer is yes so it would be
interesting to prove or refute this uh
hypothesis
so that's all we have time for today uh
if you're interested feel free to watch
the longer presentation or read the
paper um thanks for watching and enjoy
the rest of the conference
thanks a lot brian
have a good question so you can also
simulate uh
linear threshold functions is that
correct
yes or is it just
okay
uh okay great so we are running a bit uh
late so if anyone has more questions
please send them in the chat
so now uh
we we're going to start the final talk
of the session
it's going to be given by chris jones
hi chris hello let me just share my
screen
is that good
yes so we have a talk on
almost orthogonal basis for inner
product polynomials thank you chris
okay yeah thanks for coming i'm going to
talk about the space of inner product
polynomials
my name is chris and this is joint work
with aaron patechan and we're from the
university of chicago
so the story behind this talk is an
ancient one that i'm sure you've
experienced a lot of times there are two
characters in the story
the first one is just you a computer
scientist
the second character in the story is
your function f
which uh your one goal in this story is
you want to understand some properties
of the function f
and for now let's say that f is a
function on the boolean hypercube so
f
the input to f is either minus one plus
one to the n and the output is some real
number
so
if you want to
learn some properties about your
function f something that we've seen in
the previous talks in this session and
which is extremely useful
is you can express your function in the
fourier basis
so what that means for the boolean
hypercube is you just write it as a
polynomial in the input bits
and in fact when the inputs are boolean
the polynomial is multi-linear meaning
the variables all have degree at most
one
so here at the bottom of the slide i
wrote this function in the fourier basis
so maybe i don't really need to explain
some motivation for why the fourier
basis is awesome but let me tell you
some reasons anyway
so if you use the fourier basis you can
really learn a lot about your function
there's lots of nice properties that are
just immediate to read off the fourier
coefficients
and
yeah for example the mean or the
variance are very easy
one useful property of the fourier basis
is that the the basis functions are
orthonormal
when the input is random and
the randomness here is if x is uniform
from the hypercube then yeah the
monomials are orthonormal
and this technique of fourier analysis
is
more useful than just the hypercube you
can do a fourier decomposition for
functions on lots of other domains so
for example if your input comes from the
integers mod n
you can do fourier analysis if the input
is gaussian you can do something similar
and also your input comes from the
uniform interval on minus one to plus
one
and the unifying perspective that we'll
take for these different domains is that
of orthogonal polynomials we're looking
for orthogonal polynomial functions on
the input domain
i think the number one reason for using
fourier analysis is that it's really
just a great problem-solving tool so if
you just try to do it like it'll often
just solve your problem instantly
so the problem that we are facing in
this talk
is that
you don't know the fourier basis to use
for a particular domain
so what is that domain
uh your function f that you'd like to
understand
is a function of a bunch of vectors d1
through dm and each of these vectors is
n-dimensional
and the random distribution that we'll
use on the inputs is that each of the
vectors is a standard gaussian vector so
these are just standard gaussian vectors
in rn
and the constraint they will have is
that f is orthogonally invariant
and what that means
is that for every orthogonal matrix t
if t is simultaneously applied to each
of the vectors e 1 through d m
then the value of the function doesn't
change
so just to give an example of an
orthogonally invariant function you
might be computing the inner product
between d1 and d2 that function doesn't
change if you apply t to both v1 and d2
similarly if you take the product of two
inner products that's hypoglynvariant
and in fact you can show that
f must be a polynomial in these inner
product variables
d i and dj as long as f is a polynomial
function of its
inputs so for that reason we're going to
call this space the space of inner
products polynomials and our goal is to
uh provide a fourier basis for this
space
so yes let me just put that on the slide
so an inner product polynomial is a
function of a collection of vectors
which is orthogonal invariant and what
we do is we will tell you the basis that
you can use to do analysis on the space
so we provide an
the explicit orthogonal basis for
writing the function f
orthogonality comes under the gaussian
distribution of inputs
so it's not perfectly orthogonal it's
only almost orthogonal
and i
might tell you what that means you can
see the longer talk you want the formal
definition
okay so
uh let me tell you a little bit about
why this space is interesting and some
of the properties of inner product
polynomials
so that
a basis just a standard base is not not
orthogonal or anything it's is just the
inner product monomials like we said on
the fact on the previous slide
so this is a
the inner product monomials form basis
and in fact each monomial corresponds to
a multi-graph on the vertex set 1
through m
so for example i've written here two
examples of binomials
the way this corresponds to a graph
is just by putting an edge for each
inner product
so this monomial corresponds to this
graph
and this monomial corresponds to this
multi graph so you can see that the
monomials correspond to multi graphs and
they might have repeated edges and self
loops
so yeah the space of inner product
polynomials
kind of has this natural way that you
can express it in terms of graphs and
the main conceptual message of our work
is that
the inner products the functions on this
space really depend on the topological
and combinatorial properties of these
small graphs
yeah so let me explain the different way
some ways in which um that dependence
manifests itself
so okay definition let mg
be the monomial that i wrote on the
previous slide just for multi graph g
it's the
collection of inner products for that
graph so product over edges
of the inner product between du and bb
then it's not too hard to show in fact
we basically do it in the longer talk
that if you compute the expectation of
mg
then you get zero just by symmetry if
there's a vertex of odd degree in the
graph
but otherwise the magnitude of mg is
given by a topological property of the
graph g
so if if every vertex has
even degree then the graph is eulerian
at least on its connected components and
the magnitude in n is the max number of
cycles in the cycle partition of the
edges of the graph g
so that
just gives you the magnitude of the
inner product but in fact this quantity
is np hard to compute given the graph g
which is a bit of a shame
so our goal with studying these
polynomials is not to give like simple
closed form expressions because
uh they're okay you're not probably not
going to find them
it's just to give these exponential size
sums over combinatorial objects that we
can hope to understand and analyze
combinatorially so the better the
more exact statement of what i wrote
here is we show that the expectation of
mg is the sum over what we call perfect
matching collections of the graph g
of some magnitude n
i'm not going to explain the notation
completely just to put it on the slide
so you can kind of see what it looks
like this exact exponential size formula
and okay we also give
a formula for the actual basis here i've
just again written it out i'm not going
to tell you what these terms mean this
is the formula we give for the basis
elements um
in of for the almost orthogonal basis of
inner product polynomials
the basis elements are denoted pg and
there are some over some exponentially
many objects in the small graph of some
topological terms that depend on the
graph
and this is uh the definition of our
basis
so
just to
wrap up here you can again see the
longer talk if you want more details we
also define orthogonal bases for two
other input distributions the first one
being when the vectors come from the
unit sphere
and the second one being when they come
from the boolean hypercube
um yeah there's one thing to say here
about the hypercube is instead of just
working with inner products you also
have to work with some higher order
inner products
for example
the inner product of four vectors which
is something like this
so once you make that definition then
you can work get some similar formulas
in terms of exponentially many
structures on the graph
okay that's basically what i wanted to
say i'll just wrap up and say what is
this base is useful for
where might it be used in the future
so we are interested in proving sum of
squares lower bounds and we are
constructing one of these orthogonally
invariant functions
some other places where you might use it
if you're studying semi-definite
programs then we think that might be
useful because there you don't really
care about the vectors themselves you
just care about like the angles between
the vectors
anyway these uh functions also seem
related to overlaps in statistical
physics
and yeah hopefully you can find some
other reasons to study this interesting
space of functions
thanks i'll take some questions now
thanks a lot chris
questions anyone
so if not i would like to thank all the
speakers of this session
thanks everyone for joining us and don't
forget that for the next next session
you need to join room b
bye everyone
you